françois hollande prend le temps de
rencontrer ses électeurs certains
lecteurs aussi l'ex président poursuit
sa tournée de dédicaces de son livre sur
son passage à l'elysée au creusot
aujourd'hui où nous vous retrouvons
fanny borius fanni il y avait du monde
cette fois encore we are non mais bien
françois hollande se trouve maintenant
depuis près de quatre heures dans cette
librairie
il est venu dédicacer son ouvrage où il
tire les leçons de ces cinq ans à la
tête du pouvoir et permis les personnes
qui viennent le voir ce sont des
sympathisants des personnes aussi qu'ils
ont ressenti les effets positifs de sa
politique sur leur retraite ou sur leur
pouvoir d'achat et young cette séance de
dédicaces et la 65e depuis le début de
sa tournée lancée au mois d'avril et en
quelques mois
françois hollande a rencontré près de
25000 personnes des personnes qui une
houle a confié qui sans désemparer
qu'ils sont aussi pas convaincu par
l'offre politique actuelle
je vous propose d'écouter il ya donc un
risque dans notre démocratie que et puis
il y aura des colères qui ne soit pas
gratuite
qu'ils soient des désespoirs qui ne soit
pas finalement capable de donner un
résultat politique donc il est très
important que je puisse moi même leur
dire que je dois travailler comme ancien
président alors fourni
des clés des réponses ça ne veut rien
dire de plus que ça trouver la solution
ou et des solutions parce que on peut
pas laisser simplement des critiques se
faire des compétitions s'établir sans
qu'il y ait une perspective une offre
politique
la séance de dédicaces doit se terminer
maintenant dans quelques minutes
ensuite c'est un temps d'échangé avec
les militants et un temps de travail
également qui est prévu vous l'avez
compris france hollande n'a pas quitté
la politique
il est même à gauche la personnalité du
moment merci fanny borius au creuse